Android 1.0 launched in 2008 and in just
the six years since then there has been
11 new major platform releases on the
Android developer site
we show the relative number of active
Android devices running a given platform
version in this pie chart because pie
charts are awesome for our purposes
though you really better off looking at
this as a histogram if you squint you
can almost see a vaguely bell-shaped
curve with the author of releases here
at the left their popularity dropping
off as devices are upgraded or replaced
the largest proportion of devices are
here in the middle representing devices
about two years old and the newest
platforms gaining popularity as new
phones are released or upgrades go out
and here on the right so with that in
mind the min SDK acts as your low-pass
filter
Google Play won't show your app on
devices running a platform version lower
than this minimum SDK version so why not
just set the min SDK to one and support
everyone generally you'll want to target
as many users as you can but there's a
cost associated with supporting some of
these older versions things like
creating different execution paths
around deprecated or update API s or
presenting a different UX to devices
with different features so you need to
balance the opportunity of expanding
your audience with the cost of
supporting those new users also remember
that each release introduced with it new
API is and hardware support so it may
not make sense to make your app
available to devices that don't support
your minimum feature set by comparison
the target SDK is not a high-pass filter
it's used only to declare which platform
version you've tested on an app targeted
to a certain API will continue to be
forward compatible on future releases
the platform uses the target SDK values
in case of future platform makes a
significant change to expected behavior
this ensures your app doesn't break when
he uses phone gets upgraded if you're
developing a new app there's really no
reason to target anything but the latest
Android version and once your app has
been released make it a point to update
your target SDK and test as soon as
possible when you platform releases are
all out so you can take advantage of
every new platform optimization and
improvement it has to offer